the definition of the Poisson process
gives us information about the
probability that we get K arrivals
during an interval of length Delta when
Delta is a very small number how can we
find the probability of K arrivals
during an interval of some general
length tau where tau is no longer a
small number in particular we're
interested in the random variable
denoted and subtile which stands for the
number of arrivals during an interval of
length tau and we wish to find the PMF
of this random variable the probability
that n sub tau is equal to K and which
is what we have been denoting by this
particular notation in the context of
the Poisson process now if instead of
the Poisson model we had the Bernoulli
process model we would know the answer
as the number of successes or number of
arrivals in n slots has a PMF which is
given by the binomial formula can we
somehow use what we know about the
Bernoulli process to find the answer for
the Poisson process the answer is yes
and it involves a limiting argument of
the following kind we take the interval
from 0 to T and divide it into a very
large number of intervals so many of
them where each one of the intervals has
a length of Delta where Delta is a small
number and to push the analogy with the
Bernoulli process we will be calling
those little intervals as slots now
during each slot we may get 0 arrivals
one arrival but there is also the
possibility that there may be two
arrivals or even more than two arrivals
happening during one of the slots
because of this the picture that we have
here is not quite the same as for the
Bernoulli process because in the
Bernoulli process each one of the slots
we get only 0 or 1 arrival so the source
of the discrepancy between the two
models is that here a slot may obtain
two or more arrivals but how likely is
this let us look at the probability that
some slot
that is any one of the slots contains
two or more arrivals that these were
dealing with the union of the events
that slot I has two or more arrivals
this event is the union of these events
and therefore the probability of this
event is less than or equal than the sum
of the probabilities of the Constituent
events this is an inequality that we
have seen at some point in the past and
we're calling it the Union bound now
what is this summation I ranges over the
different slots and we have tau over
delta slots so there are so many terms
that are being summed now during any
particular slot the probability of two
or more arrivals is of order Delta
squared according to the definition of
the Poisson process and this quantity
converges to zero when we let Delta
become smaller and smaller so this means
that the discrepancy between the Poisson
the Bernoulli model which was due to the
possibility that we might get two or
more arrivals during one of those slots
this discrepancy is something that
happens with negligible probability in
other words the probability that we get
K arrivals in the Poisson model is
approximately the same as the
probability that K slots have an arrival
since were neglecting the possibility
that some slot has two or more arrivals
this means that the number of arrivals
in the Poisson model will be the same as
the number of slots that get an arrival
this approximate equality becomes more
and more exact as we let Delta go to
zero but now what is this quantity
the probability that K slots have an
arrival is something that we can
calculate using the binomial
probabilities each one of the slots has
a certain probability of having an
arrival and different slots are
independent of each other by the
defining properties of the Poisson
process therefore this approximation
that we have developed satisfies the
properties of the Bernoulli process we
have a certain probability that each
slot gets an arrival and we have
independence across slots this means
that we can use now the PMF that's
associated with the Bernoulli model to
calculate this quantity and then take
the limit as Delta goes to 0 to obtain a
formula for the PMF for the Poisson
process in more detail what we have is
that the number of arrivals which is
approximately the same as the number of
slots that have an arrival obeys a
binomial distribution in the limit as
Delta goes to 0 a binomial distribution
in which the probability of arrival
during each one of the slots is
approximately lambda Delta and the
number of slots goes to infinity and
this happens in a way so that the
product of the two end times P is equal
to this term times this term gives us a
lambda times tau this term times this
term give us something that's order of
Delta so it's negligible so we have this
equality and so this is approximately
lambda tau with the approximation
becoming more and more exact
as we let Delta go to zero so all we
need to do is to take the formula for
the Bernoulli process use these values
of P and N and take the limit but this
is a problem that we have already
encountered and have analyzed if we let
n go to infinity P go to zero so that
their product stays constant we have
shown that the binomial PMF converges to
the so-called Poisson PMF that takes
this form notice one small difference
and times P here is equal to lambda who
are as here n times P is equal to lambda
T this means that we need to apply this
formula but with lambda replaced by
lambda T and this gives us the final
answer this is the probability of K
arrivals during a time interval of
length T in the Poisson process and this
is a so-called Poisson PMF with
parameter lambda tau to summarize our
strategy was to argue that the Poisson
process is increasingly accurately
described by a Bernoulli process if we
discretize time in a very fine
discretization and the approximation
becomes exact in the limit when the
discretization is very fine so we took
the corresponding binomial formula for
the Bernoulli process and took the limit
that's associated with the parameters
that we would obtain if we have a very
fine discretization and this gave us the
final formula